I think Putin is misunderstood things
are misunderstood man
I think that he's been in power for a
very long time I've been extremely smart
I think he genuinely cares about Russia
and Russians about other countries we're
living in a world now where it's very
interesting to see European leaders
self-implode and self-destruct their own
gas prices their own governments their
own businesses their own populists
living standards because of some
idealistic Nation
idealistic notion that they need to help
a nation that they have no direct link
to if I'm a leader of X country I should
be concerned about ex-country more than
I'm concerned about the flight of
whatever country that's my duty and job
I think it's very interesting that most
politicians in the world today don't
seem to give it at all about the
constitute constituents they care about
aligning themselves to higher ideologies
and self-employing their own countries
and the living standards for this
ideology yeah Putin doesn't do that it's
Russia first Russia